Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Garrett Bruhat, who's a Ph.D. candidate
at the University of Rochester working at
the Laboratory of Laser Energetics, the largest
university laser lab, and one of the only
places in the world that can do laser driven
fusion experiments.
Garrett, really great having you on today.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Yeah, happy to.
Come on.
Speaker 1: David So I want to talk about this
recent breakthrough that's made a lot of news
in the field of fusion energy.
Before we even get to that.
Let's maybe develop an understanding of what
we mean when we say fusion energy.
I think for a lot of people, it's sort of
straightforward to understand, okay, you can
take something like coal and you burn it and
then you can use that heat to do different
things.
I think many people can understand that.
Or you burn gasoline in your car.
When we're talking about fusion energy.
What exactly is it?
What are we talking about?
What's the mechanism?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
So Fusion is one of the two primary forms
of nuclear energy that we can acquire right
now.
What?
We do it all over the world.
In fact, what's keeping my lights on right
now is fusion, where we split very heavy things
like uranium and utilize the heat to boil
water, turn a turbine and make power to power
our homes.
Fusion is what powers the sun.
It's also what powers our largest thermonuclear
weapons.
It's where we take very small atoms like helium
and force them together.
That generates an enormous amount of energy.
And we have never been able to do a controlled,
sustained fusion chain reaction on Earth without
a thermonuclear weapon until last week or
two weeks ago.
Speaker 1: So fusion is the coming together
of atoms in order to produce.
Is it is it accurate to say to produce heat?
Speaker 3: It produces several forms of energy,
but everything will eventually just get converted
to heat, to boil water or heat up gases or
something like that.
It's it's kind of the the old adage that no
matter what humanity does, we eventually boil
water.
Speaker 1: Right.
Okay.
So in other words, fusion is the separation
of atoms, whereas fusion is the combination.
That's the that's sort of the fundamental
difference we're talking about.
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 1: So the breakthrough, which you
alluded to at Lawrence Livermore National
Lab in California, it's being described as
a huge advancement towards nuclear fusion.
What what exactly is it that happened?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
So it is a really big scientific achievement.
It's a huge advancement.
It's been the goal essentially ever since
we discovered fusion to get a fusion chain
reaction in the laboratory.
So humanity has generated fusion chain reactions.
We did it first in the 1950s with the IT thermonuclear
weapon, and now it's some of our scariest
weapons.
But that is not useful.
That is just a capability we have.
We want fusion on a small scale controllable,
so that we can make clean sources of power.
And that has been very, very challenging to
do in what Lawrence Livermore National Labs
did, was they generated a self-sustained fusion
chain reaction in the lab no nuclear bombs,
no gigantic destruction.
Everything was controlled and done and is
repeatable.
And that has never been done before.
So it is it is a huge advancement.
It's kind of like a Kitty Hawk moment.
The airplane is finally taking off.
Speaker 1: What would it look like to use
this technology to generate the energy that
humans use for day to day lives?
What would it do?
We know what a fusion power plant would look
like.
Speaker 3: Yeah, there's a lot of different
designs using lots of different technologies.
There's a there's a huge plethora of ideas
for how to use fusion once you can get ignition,
which is what Livermore did for for your average
person, it's going to look just like a fusion
power plant.
It'll be just a big chunk of concrete that
will make an enormous amount of power for
the amount of land it takes up.
There will be no CO2 and you might see some
clouds coming out from the cooling water and
that would be about it.
Speaker 1: So with with our traditional, is
it fair to say that our traditional nuclear
power plants, these are what we would call
fission nuclear power plants?
Yes.
Speaker 3: They split atoms and thus they
do fission.
Speaker 1: At those plants.
One of the concerns that exists is what do
you do with the spent fuel and how long it
lasts, etc..
Now, I've said before I think that those who
are basing their opinion on nuclear fission
based on 40 year old plants are probably not
accurately assessing them based on what modern
plants would look like.
But putting that issue aside for a second,
you still have this issue of the spent fuel
in a fusion plant.
What are the.
Source materials and what's left over after
the fact.
Speaker 3: So the source material is some
special forms of hydrogen, but it's something
that's in the glass of water I'm drinking
from right now called deuterium.
So that's heavy hydrogen.
It's very common.
It's not a big deal.
It's used in all sorts of applications, primarily
nuclear, but even in medical tracers.
And we have effectively an infinite supply
of it.
It would, you know, the sun will be long burnt
out before we ever burn through the deuterium
supply, the type of fusion that Lawrence Livermore
did, which is the quote unquote easiest fusion
is still very, very hard.
It's called deuterium, tritium.
So the other input is a special type of radioactive
hydrogen called tritium.
Well, we have to breed that via lithium.
So from the perspective of an outside observer
ignoring all the science, the plant will eat
deuterium, which we just get from water and
a small amount of lithium.
Now we we get concerns about lithium supplies
because of electric cars and things like that.
We're talking like 100 kilos of lithium a
year for a power plant that could power a
major city.
It's not a it's not a major concern.
It's just like with vision, where the total
amount of material going in and out is just
minuscule.
There is no direct nuclear waste.
There's no spent fuel from fusion.
It just makes helium.
But it also makes an absurd number of neutrons,
which is a type of radiation, and it will
make the inside of the reactor radioactive.
There is no way to get around radioactive
waste.
Any time we do any kind of nuclear activities,
including medicine, every hospital generates
a large flux of radioactive waste.
But it's a benefit.
It's cancer treatment and therapies and all
this good stuff.
And we know how to handle the waste from these
sorts of systems.
Fusion would not generate the very long lived,
spent fuel.
As you pointed out, we can handle the spent
fuel from vision, but ignoring that fusion
won't generate it.
We're talking things more like 100 years of
radioactive lifetime, and there's ideas for
how to even shorten that.
So that that is one of the big advantages
that people point to with fusion.
Speaker 1: What are the risks of this technology
applied as a power plant, for example, to
power a city, as you mentioned?
What can go wrong?
And if something goes wrong, what happens.
Speaker 3: In some sort of kind of absurd
worst case scenario, you could have radioactive
material released to the environment.
It would be small, it would be the impact
would be very low.
The general issues would be things to people
at the plant.
Very similar to what's happened with vision
failures.
You if you worked at the plant, you'd be worried
you might have to fight a fire or something
like that.
Often fusion is in fusion.
Power plants are envisioned to use very interesting,
weird coolant.
So you imagine like flowing super hot liquid
lithium.
I'm not so afraid of the radiation.
I'm afraid of blowing liquid lithium getting
in the air because that will make a very nasty
fire.
But these are all you know, fusion is going
to be regulated just like vision.
It's going to be very, very tightly controlled.
And everyone takes this job very seriously
as to how it would be put together.
I would I would be more than willing, just
like I'm willing to live right now, right
next to efficient plant.
I wouldn't have any concern living next to
a fusion plant right now.
Speaker 1: If my understanding is still accurate.
It takes somewhere between six and ten years
to get a new nuclear fusion plant up and running.
What is the timeline?
And maybe it's hard to say because we don't
yet exactly know what these would look like.
But is there a different timeline for fusion
energy plants?
Speaker 3: There is hope that it could be
sped up, but I honestly think the sort of
things that would speed up a fusion plant
construction will speed up vision construction
as well.
A lot of the issues that we see with vision
come down to just some of the dumbest stuff,
like pouring concrete and laying steel.
Fusion requires a lot more complex equipment,
too, so it's going to be many iterations of
learning how to build these power plants before
we ever get good at it.
It's not something I would expect to see even
even if everything was ready to go tomorrow,
I wouldn't expect to see power plants just
going up left and right without massive, honestly
government support.
You have to look at how places like France
did their large vision built out.
So you just have to throw tons of money and
personnel at it.
Speaker 1: When you look at something like
let me put it a different way, when you talk
about this being difficult, fusion being difficult,
what does that really mean in the sense that
as an outsider, in my mind, it seems to me
that once you figure out what you need in
terms of equipment and you do it, you do it,
now you can replicate it.
Is there is there some chance to it where
you can do the exact same thing and it only
works some of the time at this point.
Speaker 3: So we are on.
We have just gotten ignition at Lawrence Livermore.
Arguably, we got it last year, but we don't
need to quibble about all of that.
What it is, is we're there now, but we're
only just barely getting there.
And if you've ever played around with something
like it, like doing a science experiment where
you're just figuring it out, there's often
mistakes and issues and it takes.
You just kind of have to do something over
and over and over again to learn how to do
it better.
But by difficult, what I'm actually getting
at with Fusion is that the conditions needed
to make a fusion reaction happen are very,
very, very hard to reach and the equipment
required is very expensive and complicated
when we're comparing to other sources of power,
like let's just take vision for an easy example.
You take a rock that we dig out of the ground,
turn it into a metal, stick it into water,
and the water gets hot.
For fusion, we have to have some of the largest
lasers in the world hitting little tiny targets
or massive, incredible magnets that there's
just nothing to compare to.
Now, that's not to say we can't get good at
that.
I mean, jet engines used to be one of the
most complicated and incredible things on
the planet that only militaries could afford.
And now all of us can ride on a jet aircraft.
Aircraft themselves used to be something that
almost no one could build.
But it's we are at like I said, we're kind
of at the Kitty Hawk moment.
We just got things to go.
We're not getting seven, four, seven tomorrow
if we have to say they won't happen.
Speaker 1: If we zoom out a little bit.
The feeling seems to be growing that in even
as little as 50 years, we're going to look
at the status quo of cars driving around,
burning gasoline, pulling oil out of the ground,
burning coal, this to this.
This is going to seem crazy, for lack of a
better term, right?
I mean, it seems as though we are that the
forms of energy we're using now are going
to seem almost primitive compared to what
is apparently on the horizon.
Is that the right assessment?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I would say so.
I mean, we already have a lot of options that
make what's currently powering most of the
world look primitive.
Right.
We can we can already utilize things like
nuclear fission.
We have, you know, good photovoltaic stuff
like that, the sci fi technologies here, and
it's only getting better.
Speaker 1: When people say that fusion power
is the holy grail of clean energy, this is
based on emissions specifically.
Or are there other aspects to this to.
Speaker 3: The claim, the reasoning behind
that.
And I'm not I'm not entirely sold on that
statement.
I think it's I've heard it.
I've heard it plenty of times.
I think it comes from a kind of science fiction
optimism around fusion and a lack of understanding,
or maybe not a lack, but a native to take
over some of the other sources.
Fusion is emissions free, thus the fuel supply
is effectively infinite.
Like I said, it's it doesn't matter.
There's so much.
It's we don't even need to worry about it.
And those are the big benefits on top of the
lower radioactive waste inventory.
But what I just described is basically advanced
fission as well.
And so I think that's kind of where it doesn't
always click.
It's this idea that if we got to fusion that
all our problems are solved.
But that's not really true.
One Like I said, it's going to be hard to
get these things out and cheap and effective
and reliable.
But we have options now that can reach a lot
of those goals.
Fusion, in my mind, is more filling in this
large portfolio of various energy options.
Each of them have benefits and drawbacks.
And it's not just this science fiction utopia.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask you.
What's the next step?
Is it just to repeat this very same thing
that happened, or is there some clear advanced
next step that we go to?
Speaker 3: So the immediate next step is to
repeat and get more fusion yield.
We think due to how ignition works, it's like
striking a match.
Once you can get the match to strike, you
can get more and more fire.
We think we can get a lot more fusion out
of the Livermore facility.
So they're going to work on that as hard as
possible.
But there's already designs for how to build
the next laser facilities to push this forward.
And there's other fusion concepts that can
that are being worked on other reactors.
But everyone can use the fact that we lit
the match to study how that matches lit.
Right.
And to build these next step machines.
I expect we'll see many machines reaching
ignition in the next ten years and then we
can really start to evaluate what's the best
way to move forward for power or super base
propulsion.
Speaker 1: Which is a whole other aspect to
it.
To it also.
Yeah, that that relates to the idea of going
to Mars and connects with so many other things
that are going on.
Fascinating stuff.
We've been speaking with Garrett Bruhat, who's
a Ph.D. candidate at the University of Rochester.
Garrett, really appreciate your time today.
Thank you.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thank you so much